Jim it's so good to see you again in a
very different situation from my home to
your home I mean one parent to another
parent how are the kids been doing in
isolation right now I stopped liking
them about two weeks ago it's all of
them it's insane
well you know there the thing about
distance learning is that people are
like oh you're like a teacher I'm like
you're you're like a personal assistant
you're like what can I get you okay let
me get you oh here here's your iPad oh
you need you need a photo put in this
document oh you need your passcode let
me get that for you I get it I totally
am laughing because it's so true and
it's the same thing every single day
we've adjusted we've adjusted had they
picked up in terms of responsibilities
at home well my daughter's yes but
they're they're 11 and 16 so but my
son's like I have a 7 an 8 year old son
and it's like what are you gonna what
are they gonna set an alarm for a 10:45
zoom it's like they don't know you know
like you used to just drop them off and
they wander around with the other kids I
know and you've really stepped up you do
your whole segment let's get cooking I
mean you've simplified it for me with
making toast hotdogs
pasta yes I you know I give very
insightful cooking lessons I mean some
of it is I you know we're all doing
everything right now all it's it's
amazing how much help we had that just
disappeared and so I'm making breakfast
and I'm making dinner and I'm still
doing a friend you know like nothing
compared to what my wife is doing and so
while I was doing dinner I just have one
of my kids recorded on my phone and I
pretend that I'm some master chef who's
teaching a cooking class but I'm making
like scrambled eggs
but people on YouTube like it so it's
yeah it's so entertaining I love it the
fact that you are cooking and you're
right it's three meals a day that you
have to focus on for your kids and make
sure it's something unique and different
but I love that I love the way you made
that segment you also give us an update
on quarantine how is your wife doing is
she doing really well she's doing well
she's doing well I mean we are you know
it's you know it's the experience of
quarantine is different you know like if
I was in my early 20s I don't think I
would be as quarantined as I am now and
considering my wife had a brain tumor
and subsequently got pneumonia I'm far
more quarantined than many other people
are you know but you got to be safe you
got a safe and it's all your why you me
through all of this we find ways to give
back we're front of ways to help other
people and you're fundraising for a
particular Hospital why is that well you
know some of it is it started with we
were doing we do dinner with the
Gaffigan every night at 6:00 p.m. and
now initially was just our way of maybe
reaching out to people that might be
isolated from family and friends because
I there was when I was coming back home
there was a scenario where I was gonna
have to be quarantined so I was very
mindful of the fact that people were
separated from friends and family so it
started as that but then it quickly
shifted to this fundraising thing my
wife has this organization the imagine
society which works with teens and
different youth groups and they shifted
almost immediately into helping out
health care workers and some of it is
like during dinner with egg Africans we
raise money so that we can get meals or
like you know ice cream to health care
workers after they do some insane
15-hour shift for the 60th day yeah and
you have a true appreciation of health
care workers after what your wife went
through right how is it Danny
well it's you know I I have friends that
work at these hospitals and it's pretty
intense it's you know it's you know I
know that we're all kind of joking about
you know like going stir-crazy and kind
of like distance learning but many of
these nurses and health care workers are
doing that and then going home and doing
the distance lifting so it's it's
unbelievable what these people have been
dealing with for going on sixty days you
know where they're you know they get a
day off and that day off their you know
their mom or dad it's got to be insane
gee have you talked to your kids about
it everything that's happening
yeah well that's some of what dinner
with the Gaffigan has been really
beneficial outside of the fact that we
have dinner every night at 6:00 p.m. is
we have you know it's a good way to
articulate with the kids what's going on
and why we're raising this money because
it's like to a 7 or a an 11 year old you
know they they might understand some of
it they're just you know initially they
just understood that school was
cancelled or they couldn't see their
friends but so it's I think it's
important for them to understand some
empathy because some people are dealing
you know and it's it's everywhere right
it's like you know it's not just in big
cities like New York and Toronto it's
like it's starting to hit everywhere and
these health care workers you know
beside it's the family members that are
dealing with this but it's intense
mm-hmm and talking about dinner do you
know some of these staple meals that are
created in Canada oh well I know
well there's kraft mac and cheese right
yes that's the big one that's so but you
know yes
salmon in Vancouver yes we do yes yes
poutine the Maritimes they have a lot of
seafood right and dulse mm-hmm name the
seaweed because there why there but I
don't know of other ones
okay well poutine by the way and also
like there's the poutine but it's very
uh and by the way I have a comedy
special coming out that's all about
Canada and so I talked about how like
poutine and different parts of Canada so
like where there's a lot of Ukrainians
it's pierogi poutine which as if anyone
needs that you know what this Carboni
more carb we have ketchup chips yes
coffee crisp chocolate bars have you had
that no yeah I've got you know there's
great obviously there's great Canadian
comedians and so yeah one of my friends
Ian bagg his mom used to send him
Canadian candy bars because all the
American candy bars were trash that's
right but you need to know because I
just found out that you are gonna take
on the role of the infamous Toronto
Mayor Rob Ford I need to know what
convinced you to take this role on and
what do you know about him at least how
was he represented in the US well I mean
how do you answer this I say I was
initially I was approached with the
script and I you know I obviously knew
about Rob Ford I knew that he was you
know the populism and the really that we
can historically know he was the
predecessor to Trump right stop the
gravy train was just keep him make
America and then at different form right
and so I you know but the more research
and working on the script and it's all
Canadians involved it was
it was really you know like there's a
real human side to it you know there is
and the people involved you know the
police chief the the reporter you know
there is a the young Somali guy you know
it's it's you know it's a real human
story and it's it's Shakespearean really
you know it's it's also kind of sad
because I mean I you know Rob you know
from the research I've done it's like he
probably should have just been a
football coach dear I mean that's
probably what he should have done but
family pressure and stuff like that but
I don't know there's it's it's a pretty
huge task and I wish Chris Farley was
around to play him but ah you know it's
he's such a character right and there's
such a comedic side to him and he's so
you know like when I think of Toronto
you know I don't think of Rob Ford
I think of Toronto and a different like
he seems different but like I also the
fact that he is different because I
think it also has something to do with
class you're I mean no it's fascinating
as an actor it's just a fascinating
opportunity to know you're looking
forward to doing it oh yeah yeah no it's
like I mean it's social media people
have been very you know like some people
are angry that that we're glorifying
this or there are people that are
reaching out saying hey I know things
about him you know that you need to find
out about you know but it's it's this
it's really kind of a neverending story
right because nagas is you know he's
pretty high up the food chain yeah I
mean so it's it's a the interesting
thing and so like but I'm as an actor
I'm just you know I want to play a
character that's complex and has a lot
of dimension and so
brob for it's great yeah there's a lot
of dimension of you by any chance
connected with Doug port our Premier of
Ontario have you guys talked yet about
this whole bag no it's so interesting
because there's you know there's a lot
of Canadians involved in this right and
as we were going around pitching it
there was always the discussion of you
know the positive or negative
associations with this within Canada and
you know being an American I'm kind of
just standing back and you know I'm not
you know I don't have that knowledge and
so it'll be interesting to see you know
we're still in this initial face the
entertainment industry this you know
hopefully this will happen but I don't
know yeah I mean yeah it's amazing and
I'm looking forward to taking on this
role I think you're perfect for it and
when I heard about like yes he's the
right person because it is gonna be a
bit of a dark comedy at the end of the
day right